all right here we go
less than 10 seconds eighty-seven
players a little over 1800 average
rating time handicapped 30 minutes no
criteria necessary to enter war zone
rated I forgot I should be moving I was
too concerned about the timer watch out
for h7 watch out for h7 age 7 we're
gonna have h7 being hit can't take this
pawn because of tricky stuff I'll let
that pawn fall I'll let them fall I
might let two pawns fall for some attack
okay for some attack okay no we'll try
this and then Queen out can I make this
a problem for black actually let me do
this and hit this Queen hit the Queen
and then okay well that's a pain rook c1
I want to keep the Queens on the board
needed this pawn could be a thorn I
could get it f7 one day rook c1 this
pond is gonna be taken isn't it get that
Queen on there I want to take this pawn
as clean as a pain get out of here
get out of here okay now this pawn is
gonna fall now he's down with a fork
tricky tricky Forks beware of them
they're dangerous those Forks are very
dangerous check in here no matter what
now the night isn't a pin the night is
down the queen is on the scene here here
no matter what with check here no matter
what main threat on f7 I'll just take
care either one would have been me back
to tournament land - somebody has 12
Wow what is going on why does somebody
have 12 Sicilian Sicilian watch out for
the fishing poles watch out for the
fishing poles I'm in a fork 'if I would
have been nice it definitely would have
been nice for 14 white oh no oh no no no
no let's come over here I think whether
a rucksack would have been dangerous
would have been dangerous very dangerous
where's this night gun let's get the
ocean take this pine I would I played a
v8 just a bluff I was a free pot let's
come back but not all the way let's come
back but not all the way get this clean
out of here she's nothing but trouble
she's nothing but trouble get out of
here night grab this night get this guy
going my light-square bishop would love
to do something he's doing something now
pawn push pivot point on b2 double the
rooks stay out of here are you dropping
this pawn though yep they were all over
that one all over it all over it grabbed
this pawn pigs oh I can also take that
let's get my pawns going I'm dropping a
bishop they're gonna grab this I'll take
that this is leading to me that's nice
that's convenient mates are convenient
remember that back to tournament 1410
seven playing against a lot of different
players it's probably because I'm
playing in a different time it's bound
to happen is it Alec I'm a yakin all
right let's see this often do you okay
structural damage structural damage
Bishop d7 I don't understand what did
Bishop d7 is doing do I does every move
have to have a meaning is that is that
what I'm getting at
it really doesn't
is that what it really means that [ __ ]
up let's kill this [ __ ] up I'm not
really killing it getting it to a better
square me you got a mate here whoo age
seven age seven uh-oh aah all right
let's break this down here
break it down f6 have six tricky
discoveries beware beware of the tricky
discoveries whoa all right I guess I
gotta go with that 25 seconds is not a
lot on a pile up on this guy he's a weak
link and enough defense for him
you got enough defense get rid of a
liability on Dean take that pawn I don't
even know what I'm doing I better watch
I don't get mated take with the pond why
did I take with the pond five answers to
these questions help them out now uh
them for me please look here I don't
have any time
where did my time go my king is stupid
okay let's grab this rooks a pair of
rooks off the board
ah
can I get the rooks off the board please
oh no wow this is like a losing king
upon endgame isn't it
can you pond end game
this is too close it's too close until
you get a queen until you get a queen
that wasn't a good idea by me stepladder
where are you a stepladder I need a
stepladder
where are the step ladders there it is
finally that took forever my phone had
point one I thought I had point one all
right skip the bead stuff that happens
behind the scenes my heart skipping a
beat right there holding your breath
going blind sometimes if you fall for
the scholars main thing I got already
watch part of these to realize what I'm
even saying h2 that's what I'm saying
right now that's what I'm fishing for oh
yeah
get out of there Bishop you have no
business being there alright let's go
first center center is nice Bishop check
oh this pocket turned out to be a thorn
he could turn out to be a thorn a thorn
whoa the king is a maniac Wow is he
dangerous whoa the bishop has to give
itself up boom right in the center often
you see that one hang on hang on it's
still dangerous somehow take here and
then get my other rook doing something
exciting check here check here check
everywhere okay now things are smooth
where's the mane where is that me it
should be like here by now where does
that mean okay now we got a mate now we
got that no it's still not me he's the
king of ring-around-the-rosie variation
oh man he was a dancing King if I've
ever seen it a dancing King there's not
only the dancing Queens
there's the dancing Kings he's still
running oh I can't get this king he
the sneakiest king around finally whoa
did I have to hunt him down how many
matin ones did I miss okay it's been a
while since I'd Oh back to tournament 36
27 26 25 Wow a tight pack up here okay
here we go
this is Cillian the bullet zones free oh
I just dropped a pun that's wonderful
it's wonderful to drop a pond in just a
couple moves sneak attack with tier ok
the bishops shutout the game that's nice
all right checks block okay for a second
I was thinking about giving up my bishop
all right I'm dropping this okay can I
target this pawn though this is gonna be
a nice home nice home for those nights
for sure so that's why I'm taking up
this pond so I could remove that home
remove that home remove those homes all
right let's do this Queen over night
here man that tricky Knight he's gonna
kill me I could feel it I could feel it
he's gonna kill me pin that night no not
just yet let's get here Wow
okay this is actually working now kick
this night away and then I could grab
this Knight
no trickiness right there let's just
come here
keep my queen around let's trade it a
little bit could we trade fan of trading
no gone far enough
let's get out of pens maybe let's get
out of those pins double up we're on
push is probably okay
okay no I can't do that you can't do
that 20 seconds I actually have a lead
on the clock
it's a nice thing it's definitely a nice
thing all right let's just guard can i
guard everything get out of stuff here I
said II moved that pond what would that
even do okay my knight wants to be where
my knight wants to be on g3 g3 coming up
no matter what
deadly fork I could have also taken the
Queen okay they reached now that they're
down in time 50 40 to 39 38 37 Wow
oh wow again III okay I got to make this
work
gotta make III work I think I can I move
they're not gonna move I could use this
Elvis come on Elvis yes
bacterium in 66 44-42 whoo we're not
even halfway there
we're not even halfway there is this guy
gonna move yes he is okay open Sicilian
seen it before you'll see it again Queen
c7 Knight f6 Knight g4 once it's
supported I just thought for a second
was my move when my opponent wasn't
moving just then I'm still gonna do this
open up the H file no I don't want to do
that anymore okay let's do this I want
to keep my Bishop right there it could
also hit at this pawn move already
move your age pawn can hear that beam
uh-oh
I have a trick up my sleeve I have a
trick up my sleeve Bishop c5 take here a
couple times and then it leads to me
let's see if that works
Knight here Bishop back still it's right
here there's an issue on g3 King up
maybe a thorn push h3 becomes a thorn
this is a serious threat pawn takes
Queen takes leads to me all right right
here I think I could still take here
okay now it's happening I mean I want if
takes might have it pawn is pinned game
back to tournament sixty six sixty sixty
fifty three fifty seventeen minutes
remaining
okay let's go efore scheming avian
Scandinavian okay let's not drop upon
like it did in that game at one game not
the last game okay let's stop Bishop
here Queen d2 Castle queenside I guess I
gotta watch out for a night maybe
getting here but now let's just work
hassle an opposite side so what does
that mean
okay I'm defending that pawn I didn't
realize that okay now they gave up their
dark square bishop oh now I gave up a
pawn
okay it's still gonna be okay opposite
opposite color bishops I can't contest
the defiled just yet and my bishop is
gonna be a giant paint on h6 possible
back rank issues we're gonna see about
that can I get these pawns going that
night is not bothering me just yet I
want to keep this tricky night on the
board okay I want to get an f5 this
Bishop is close to being killed if the G
file opens up maybe there's an issue
okay now this pawn is gonna be okay
let's open up the H file actually and
then play my Bishop to g7 then made on H
a are they gonna allow me to do that
should take with this pawn I'm gonna do
that just to I'm not sure what okay
let's come over here this is not good
this is not good at all I think gonna
take that it's probably okay to take it
let's see about that though let's see
about it
oh there's no there's a bishop check
okay this is actually good it's stopping
checks here oh no no no no no 15 seconds
oh no no no I think it's okay we're
gonna have me
don't make me let's come over here
that's not gonna
aah wait a second check check I don't
have it read I just want to do now I
should have done that well it just gets
rid of fun what discover tricks
what does that even do I need time
burners Mike King he's stupid no no no
I'm not gonna risk just time burners
anything anything back to tournament
that was stupid I don't even know I
don't I can't describe these things just
label that one's stupid that game is
just stupid every move I made was stupid
ah okay these are tough the Dodger game
here is tough if you think it's easy
you're wrong you're wrong you're wrong
if you think it's easy okay let's get
Castle here
let's get castled this pawn isn't a pin
dad he isn't a pin
oh man okay they'd probably be some sack
right there let's get rid of that okay
this night is gonna kill me okay okay I
think I have to take care first maybe oh
no no no no no no pancakes with check
they had pancakes with check whoa well
they're pre moving everything I could
have taken the rook as well what am i
doing they resigned back to tournament
28 128 122 98 I don't even know what
things are happening way too fast way
too fast another French is this the guy
played in the first round I'm gonna let
that pong be taken and then secure my
bishops position this is a gambit line
support this pun Oh what are they doing
they giving me these I should have taken
that that would have been better you
grab it you get it rook done looks are
better than pawns remember that remember
that rooks are better than pawns in
those cases got a castle a castle I need
some more information Castle please no
okay they still can't castle really my
f-pawn working can't do that there's a
fork deadly fork deadly fork let's open
this position up I mean a check let's do
a queen trade my favorite my favorite
mmm-hmm does it matter how I took right
there oh it matters if I play my rook
right there they didn't take it though
oh I'm in a floor it gets okay though
okay I need to stay coordinated I need
to start moving like I might I might
Mouse lip or something oh man my heart
skipped a beat my heart skipped skipped
a beat here we go get that pond to
victory lane to victory lane where is
the main inch the king over it's gonna
be some sneak attack I knew it I knew it
I knew there would be a sneak attack
okay I got it that's what I was trying
to do that was probably not the cleanest
way to do it 148 142 118 12 minutes
remaining this guy's up there 101 should
I be trying sneaky tactics against this
guy we're not gonna have that with the
Benoni with the Benoni
okay this is probably not good but
probably not good but we're gonna try it
we are gonna try it aren't we okay I
don't know if it's a good idea to Castle
I don't think um just b5 sump on sac now
to try something to open this stuff up
now you get at that d5 pawn if g5 then I
jump into where I got this right here
pawn push as well jump right in here as
soon as the knight moves I don't want to
take me that dark square bishop maybe
and we need to get rid of that Knight
really soon why did I take that I'm in
trouble something with this this Knight
check and stuff I have this covered
fortunately temple gainers I want to
remove that night move that night I got
a watch out for me here oh shoot that
was a bad move that was a bad move
just take that not they could have taken
me right there okay
clean check I'm gonna do a queen block
they're not let's take care and then
here this is very unfortunate I have at
a time edge whoa now that is what you
call dangerous this is dangerous
I don't have any time what do I need to
do oh man oh I just dropped a rook they
can't go to the corner my bishops there
oh I can't move
oh I'm down a time and position oh man
that was bad that battery was so
dangerous oh man oh oh he was up there
too he's probably ahead of me now oh
that one's stung
ah ah that hurts I need to try some wild
tricks now you know what that involves
it involves the h-file every time every
time it involves the h-file um could I
somehow win this still I have to take
here I have to do tricky stuff tricky
stuff I don't want to remove my uh the
bishops gonna play here what am i doing
I gotta try this this isn't even working
well I'm I'm on tilt I'm on tilt never
plan tilt never oh no no no no all that
pine is going down in flames yes he is I
don't have any chance what am i doing
I'm in big trouble
I'm in very big trouble yeah I'm in
really really big trouble
when you have to do those moves you know
you're in trouble I can't move now oh
I'm in such big trouble right now
where am I can I save this
can I save this somehow somehow there's
no way there's no way you can't come
back from this oh gotta run over here
gotta run over here please run over here
where is the save I don't even know what
I'm doing with these moves can I get a
tricky night move somehow nope that's
not even working I'm getting mated man
this is bad
tricky night save the day oh I'm down on
time even I could only get a drop do you
realize that could only ever get a draw
tricky night saved the day somehow he's
not around black Quinn I'm down again oh
no you got to recover seven minutes left
ah come on oh man oh that was terrible I
was sacking the house on that one why do
I feel like I should be sacking the
house oh no no no
ah can I get a mate here real quick
where are the maids they're nowhere to
be found
they're nowhere to be found okay the
bishop is gonna kill me right here
no no it's not okay let's kick the queen
and then jump in here c4 ah
what's that doing the G the B file is
opened up okay here we go here we go
pileup on that night it's in the pen why
did I my queen is being trend that is an
annoying check isn't it it's gotta be
it's got to be an annoying check coming
through here I could have taken that
with check and then gotten the Queen
what am i doing okay I think I could win
this one I'd better be able to win this
one I'd better be able to win this one
okay take a clean man
grab here where are the mates
where are the maids back to tournament
226 Wow I'm looking at 178 I have to
somehow get to 178 five minutes
remaining not happening not happening
and this game is not starting oh wait is
is this gonna get hit me with the air
and then give me points oh no come on
you got to start up you have to start up
here right ah it's not starting
I'm lucky if I get top ten 246 who is
that beast huh oh no it's not starting
come on you gotta start they're not
starting it up let's see that guy how is
he what is he eating
he's eating a lot of granola bars or
something 246 beefy points there's an
air there's the air
what'd I get what did I get some points
for that
I don't even see um okay I got to stay
focused here I have to stay focused
um I need like three fishing poles to
land back-to-back-to-back there is no
pod push queen H can I get this Knight
g4 stuff done I got killed on f7
actually it would have been me but been
close to it bishop here my opponent has
a lot of development just offer a queen
exchange I guess it's not gonna be a
quick kill but everything is gonna be
safe I think yes I'm getting this take
this Queen around a little bit defend my
bishop and then push this pawn drop my
Queen back I guess now let's get this
pawn rolling get developed and then just
swing my Queen over I guess no not so
fast okay
I'm push pawn push again I'm on the
Queen should I disguise it a bit more no
I was thinking rook G first and then the
pawn push making one threat that I tried
these sneaky tricks right here weakened
that structure h3 that first game at
loss I was just thinking about it right
now I spent so much time once that rook
went to where I can't shake that one I
keep thinking about it keep thinking
about that one
okay pawn here maybe I should have just
done it right away right away here no
matter what they're in a pin pawn push
with promotion where is the main they're
down in time back to tournament leaders
leaders leaders 266 - 18 to 14 forget
about top three I'm struggling to get
top ten
where's top ten there's only two -
there's less than three minutes
remaining
less than three in the bullet zone 3 F 4
ok I'll do that and then get castled
night here threatening a fork
ok that's hitting everything the Queen
can play their wit's check that would
have been a way to get out of it okay
let's let's open up stuff Queen can
still give a check here my knight I've
just double rooks I guess there's a
check but I don't think it leads to
anything double rooks and then smash
through I'm in a pin I'll try and get
out of it soon or I should just done
that that's better
hit the Queen and the knight deadly fork
I'll just take it I'm up another piece
I'm up a rook I'm up a full rook now
less than two minutes remaining
can I get maybe one more game in after
this I have to conserve time in my
King's help sneak up here okay but here
check
that's me okay back to tournament 184 to
84 to 86 24 games how do you get 24
games in this guy's negative 30 negative
30 he's up there he's strong player 2
back to tournament o2o4 122 remaining he
for 115 remaining 115 remaining okay
Sicilian I gotta go for a quick kill
this game is not gonna finish not gonna
finish
III Queenie
d3 Queenie one Queen g3 f5 there
queenside castle that night and I can
think twice while castling in that
direction all right let's see pond push
inside castle my knight wants to be on
b6 hitting the night let's come back
actually I got to break it open I got to
try and win fast gotta try and win fast
all right that is very very very
dangerous move okay now I'm getting some
material 23 seconds though it's only 23
seconds remaining to fork oh it's not
gonna finish
not even close not even close might be a
bishop check I could block on to e3 my
Queens there to defend 20 oh it's not
happening
that's it it says it's complete it says
it's complete are they gonna know if
thanks for playing 8 ah let's close out
of that
286 264 man I only had 17 games in 24 24
21 18 286 267 258 254 beasts that is
crazy 286 very good
I was I took a couple beatings in that
too and another one that I should have
just lost probably or many of them could
games out